you look amazing yeah very very happy oh
yeah I'm so happy out here supporting my
girl Jennifer Aniston and Reese
Witherspoon hi guys
no fun you know I love first of all I
love the show I've seen the first three
episodes but I love that hindi owned by
these women like they got it done it's
just just doing it for themselves
women women supporting women women
taking their own narrative and putting
it in their own words I think that is
the most important thing about this this
whole thing and the time that we're in
I'm so excited to be at this for we're
you know in our business in the
competitive world of journalism it's all
about getting that big get interview
like we want the big one so if you were
doing this in real life who would be
that big get interview that you would
want and you need right now okay well
for pretty big deal which is my podcast
which is coming out very soon you guys
don't know dawg I mean I would love to
have Jennifer Lopez a Michelle Obama
definitely I mean there's also our team
by the Oprah come on I mean why not
Jennifer Aniston Reese Witherspoon like
you know what we're gonna shoot for the
stars all those ladies yeah you know
Jennifer just broke the internet a
couple weeks ago okay yeah when she
joined Instagram oh yes no Jennifer
Aniston congratulations but we've we've
been DMing like she's she the girl that
she is on TV is the girl that she is
behind the scenes so she actually uses
Instagram yes she uses it cuz I blew her
up I was like hey girl welcome thank you
and we had a little combo I'm telling
you it's real she's real honest we
always think somebody runs a celebrity
he's running hers I know big news I love
it I love that too so what's the next
social goal that she should try and hit
well she hit one five hours a million
followers who does that nobody but
Jennifer Aniston congratulations
I love it so much I'm also there's so
many celeb cameos in this I don't know
if you know everybody that kind of pop
in but when you're watching who do you
want to see who would you love to see
celebrity wise just pop into this range
oh my gosh I mean there's just so many
great people that
part of the film or a by the show it's
not even a film it's a show already I'm
just happy to be here in supporting but
it feels like a movie ok tell us all
about how you feel like feeling good I
can't stop rubbing the balm cantaloupe
celery cucumber those have been like my
three biggest cravings wait a minute
you're craving your cantaloupe celery
and cucumber weird I know I'm like kind
of happy about it but also like I wanted
to like you know I wanted to eat french
fries every day but I don't want it you
know if you're having a boy or girl I do
are you telling no looking at you and
your hubby that baby is going to be a
good good good good gorgeous how much
longer do you have left I have a little
bit left I love it what can I get a side
just a side shot before you go hi baby
you look gorgeous
[Music]
you